seven studio albums later third eye
blind is bringing their signature sound
to a new generation all while trying to
fight climate change the band is
donating a portion of the ticket sales
from their 25th anniversary tour to the
non-profit sea trees which is working to
restore a kelp forest off the california
coast
third eye blinds front man steven
jenkins joins us now first on cbs
mornings to talk about the effort to
fight climate change also talk about 25
years later as a guy who was in high
school listening to that untitled album
uh gosh has it really been 25 years
it really has and the only thing i can
say about that song because i just have
nothing to say about it is that
first of all hi you guys hi hey hi steve
i i'm actually a morning person which is
it means i really have the wrong job
because i stay up late uh-huh
everyone's so cheerful it's just a good
vibe here very happy to be here thanks
for having me on your show anyway the
only thing i could say about that song
is that i'm wearing the same pants that
i that i just realized
i'm wearing the same pants right now
that i wore in that video the same exact
pair from 25.
wow are those pants
that's personal growth i guess in a way
don't change don't innovate yeah did you
know you had
an iconic song and that's not the only
iconic song on the album by the way when
you guys were making it just before
release did you feel you're on the
precipice of something big
no i didn't think it would get played on
the radio because it's a filthy dirty
naughty little song yeah if you listen
closely yeah yeah clearly they did but
the beat's so good
thank you and so catchy yeah you got a
glass bottle there uh part of your
effort to fight climate change started
with plastic bottles at your concerts
what that's how it started yeah what was
the moment for you
you guys had a really good segment this
morning i saw that on on plastic um and
it's great that there are efforts to
to recycle plastic but it's it's it's a
flawed effort so
the idea
that we in the society go oh yeah we
have to have plastic bottles
and you know you used to used to demand
tap water that was really good new york
you know uh new york city tap san
francisco tap it's all great and somehow
that sort of got expanded out into we
have to have a plastic bottle that ends
up in the ocean i would see these things
on surf trips
in indonesia
and we realized how many that we were
using on tour so all we did was say i
said
we're not going to have any more plastic
bottles at all if you want to be
backstage
at a third eye blind show then we're
going to have water cooler and you can
just get one of these and in one summer
tour
we estimated that we saved
17 000 plastic bottles from one tour on
tour and and now you're focusing on kelp
i have to tell you before i met you i
hadn't given a thought to kelp because i
think of it as
slimy and sticky and wraps around you i
didn't see it as something that we
should care about
and you say
that sounds good
slimy and sticky and steamy sounds good
yeah that sounds like uh like spa day
doesn't it yeah it sounds like a kelp
wrap yes but the reason why we should
care is what stephen why should we
understand this because you know
people's eyes glaze over at this stuff
sometimes and you need to make sure they
understand this is very important
there are dolphins in the hudson river
right now because the hudson is cleaner
now
than it's been since the civil war
that's a miracle
it's amazing what is happening
on the west coast
we have the opportunity
to
reforest
the sea off the coast of california
kelp which is the these are the giant
trees um and that's why we support a
group called sea trees
kelp sequesters
40 more carbon by biomass
than a redwood tree does
20 times more per acre than a forest
does and by sequester what i mean it
mean is that it pulls carbon out of the
air
and turns it into this plant that then
when it dies it sinks off into the ocean
and it sequesters that carbon for
thousands of years it works amazingly
and if we don't if we don't do it we may
not have a future but so let's talk
about the past oh we have a future
i know we have a beautiful bright future
yeah you're very optimistic
we can't there are things we can do
steven you didn't give there was no
title to the album that had semi-term
life on it and jumper uh and how's it
going to be if you could give it a title
now what would it be
i don't know
untitled
there you have it breaking news the
final album is now officially untitled
stephen jenkins thank you very much we
appreciate it happy to be here